[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ولد القارئ الماليزي عبد الكريم بن عمر
لابن حافظ للقران الكريم درس في اكناف
الحرم المكي الشريف وفي هذه الاجواء
الروحانيه نشا القارئ عبد الكريم ووضب على
حلقات تحفيظ القران منذ الطفوله ليتنقل
لاحقا بين مراكز ومدارس قرانيه مستزيدا من
الحفظ وراغبا مقبلا على فنون القراءه
والتجويد حتى بات قادرا على التصدر
للامامه
ولدت في مكه المكرمه ودرست تحفيظ في مسجد
الحرام كان الوالي رحمه الله عليه كان
حريص ان ارافقه كل يوم كان الوالي رحمه
الله عليه كان يدرس في الحرم فانا كنت
ارافقه دائما والحمد لله حبيت اجواء
خصوصا في المسجد الحرام
ودرسنا هناك الحمد لله
والى ان توظفنا في هذا المسجد المبارك
واخدم في هذا المسجد المبارك قرابه 12 سنه
درست تحفيظ ثم تلقيت مع احد القراء في مكه
المكرمه لاتقان في
تجويد
ودرست بعض
العلوم الشرعيه هناك في الطائف اثناء عمري
15 سنه انتقل الوالد الى الطائف ودرست
هناك ودرست تحفيظ ايضا في الطائف
وتعلمت القراءه من كثر السماع يعني انا
احب اسمع القراء والمشايخ
وحاول ان احاكيهم قدما استطيع لان
المحاكاه
الكباريه او القراء المعروفين هذا شرف لنا
فالحمد لله اجواء الحرم كما تعلم
الروحانيه
خصوصا يعني دائما استمع للقراء والمشايخ
كثره الائمه والمؤذنين لان انا من عشاق
القراء والمؤذنين فالحرم يعني علمني كثير
العلوم الامامه بطريقه الاداء
السليم
في الامامه والاذان تاثرت
الشيخ محمد ايوب رحمه الله عليه امام مسجد
النبوي وايضا امام مسجد الحرام في صلاه
التراويح الشيخ علي جابر رحمه الله عليه
والشيخ علي الحذيفي ايضا امام مسجد النبوي
كان يصلي بنا في مكه المكرمه صلاه
التراويح ولا انسى شيخنا الفاضل معالي
الدكتور الشيخ عبد الرحمن السديس
زارنا في ماليزيا
وقرات عنده والحمد لله
فهو
اللي اثر به كثيرا طبعا اسلوب قراءته
وكثير من المشايخ الشيخ الان يعني مثل
الشيخ ماهر المعيقلي الشيخ ياسر الدوسري
وبقيه المشايخ سال عليكم ما تيسر من اواخر
سوره البقره
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرج
[موسيقى]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
لله ما في السماوات وما في الارض
وان تبدوا ما في
انفسكم او تخفوه
يحاسبكم به
الله فيغفر لمن
يشاء
ويعذب من
والله على كل شيء
[موسيقى]
قدير
امن الرسول
بما
انزل اليه من ربه والمؤمنون
كل امن بالله و
اولائكته وكتبه ورسله
لا نفرق بين احد
من رسله
وقالوا سمعنا واطعنا
غفرانك ربنا واليك المص
ير لا يكلف الله نفسا الا وسعها لها ما
كسبت وعليها ما اكتسبت
ربنا لا
تؤاخذنا ان نسي
نا او اخطانا
ربنا ولا تحمل علينا
اصرا كما حملته على الذين
من قبلنا
ربنا ولا
تحملنا ما لا طاقه لنا به
واعف عنا واغفر لنا
وارحمنا
انت مولانا
فانصرنا على القوم
الكافرين
صدق الله
العظيم
اولا شاركت في
امينه المصلين اول مره في حياتي في الطائف
كان عمري 14 سنه
فبدايات يعني كانت
صعبه شويه لاني انا طبعا كان عمري صغير
وما عندي من الخبرات لكن الحمد لله
حبي
للامامه والاذان يعني جعلني دائما
اراجع
واستشير من الائمه الكبار
واتعلم منهم والانسان يتعلم من اخطائه
فبدايه في عمر 14 صليت في الطائف ثم
درست كملت دراستي في الرياض في المحلات
الجامعيه واميت ايضا في مسجد الجامع في
السكن الجامعي وخارج للجامعه
وشاركت ايضا كذا مشاركات عديده ايضا اثناء
وجودي في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
كقاري في مناسبات مع الملك عبدالله رحمه
الله عليه والامير سلطان بن عبد العزيز
رحمه الله عليهم
هناك كسبت خبرات
ومراجعتي مع المشايخ لانني لا اتقن
القراءه السليمه وعندي بعض الاخطاء والى
الان اتعلم والى الان انا اتعلم من
المشايخ والقراء
ان صدفتني
اللقاء
صدفني اللقاء مع المشايخ فانا اول طالب
اتلقي العلوم الشرعيه والعلوم خصوصها في
مجال التجويد لان القران بالنسبه لي صعبه
فالانسان يعني لابد ان يكون دائما يتعلم
القران يعني القران ليس فقط في سن معين ان
يتقن او يقرا القران ويحفظ القران بل
القران مدى الحياه
فانصح يعني الجميع انه دائما يتعلم ويتعلم
الى اخر الحياه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
بعد تجربه في الامامه بعدد من المساجد عاد
القارئ عبد الكريم بن عمر الى موطنه في
ماليزيا دون انقطاع عن الحلقات والدروس
والمناسبات القرانيه حتى اهلته تجربته الى
امامه اكبر مساجد ماليزيا وهو مسجد
السلطان صلاح الدين شاه المعروف بالمسجد
الازرق وهو اكبر مساجد ماليزيا وابرز
معالمها الاسلاميه ونقاط جذبها السياحيه
شاركت ايضا في مسابقات تحفيظ القران
وشاركت ايضا
في مسابقات الاذان
والحمد لله هذه خبره يعني يعني الانسان
دائما يحاول ان يشارك في كذا مشاركه
واتمنى ان اشارك ايضا مستقبلا في اي
مسابقه لان هذه يعني يرغب الواحد يراجع
القران
ويتعلم من زملائه ومن مشايخه
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
على
[موسيقى]
حي على الفلاح
الله
اكبر الله اكبر
لا اله الا الله
تحيات في هذا المسجد المبارك في عام 2010
اول ما تخرجت المرحله الجامعيه
في هذا المسجد المبارك
طبعا ليس لدي خلفيه عن الامامه في ماليزيا
وايضا لا اجيد كثيرا يعني اللهجه
الماليزيه مع انها اللغه الام بالنسبه لي
لكن المواليد مكه المكرمه لكن الحمد لله
الى الان اجيد اللهجه الماليزيه او
الملايويه الى 90% ولله الحمد والمنه
فكانت مرحله صعبه قليلا في البدايه والى
الان الحمد لله
بدانا يعني نحفظ الشباب ونراقبهم حبهم
للقران
و وجودي في المجتمع هنا
محافظ القران وان راغب الشباب والمجتمع
كبار السن في المحاضره سواء في داخل هذا
المسجد المبارك او في خارج المسجد على حسب
المناسبات والدعوه يعني قد اصلي بالناس
حسب المسجد يعني دعوه المسجد ان الصليب
المغرب والعشاء ومن هناك القلم محاضره عن
القران والتجويد وهكذا عندنا تسعه ائمه
وتقريبا سته او سبعه مؤذن في هذا المسجد
ولدينا من الموظفين اقل من 50 موظف
والجماعه
الاول المصلين عامه الجماعه عندنا هنا
تقريبا
فوق ال 10,000 نعم صلاه الجمعه اكثر من
10,000
وصلاه العيد ايضا
عدد المصلين تقريبا اكثر من عشره الاف اما
في الصلوات المفروض العاديه اليوميه
تقريبا الى 300 الى
4500 مصننه ما يميز هذا المسجد المنارات
وعندك ايضا القبه الزرقاء طبعا كانت في
الثمانينات او تسعينات من اكبر
القبب في على مستوى اسيا تقريبا
[موسيقى]
اكثرهم السياح ياتون من الصين ومن اليابان
ومن الدول العربيه ايضا والمسجد مفتوح
يعني للجميع لكن عندنا هناك ملابس خاصه
للزوار حتى يدخلون المسجد يعني ما يدخلون
باللبس القصير او يدخلون مثلا باللبس
الغير محدثه للمسجد احتراما للمسجد عندنا
ملابس خاصه للسياح
وعندنا من الموظفين
المتطوعين الذين يجيدون اللهجه اليابانيه
والنهجه العربيه موجودين عندنا في مكتبهما
الخاص في خارج المسجد هم يستقطبون السياح
هم يعني يشرحون لهم المسجد وضواحيه
يا ايها الذين امنوا قوا
انفسكم واهليكم نارا
نارا
وقودها الناس والحجاره عليها
ملائكه
غلاظ شداد لا يعصون الله ما امرهم ويفعلون
ما يؤمرون يا ايها الذين كفروا لا تعتذروا
اليوم
انما تجزون ما كنتم تعملون يا ايها الذين
امنوا توبوا الى الله توبه
نصوحا عسى ربكم ان يكفر عنكم
سيئاتكم
ويدخلكم جنات تجري من تحتها الانهار يوم
لا يخزي الله النبي والذين امنوا معه
نورهم يسعى بين ايديهم
وبايمانهم يقولون ربنا اتمم لنا نورنا
واغفر لنا
انك على كل شيء قدير
لحفظ القران الواحد لازم ينوي النيه
الصادقه حفظ القران ليس لاجل رغبه الوالد
او رغبه
فلان يعني اغرب رغبه لنفسك انت يعني انت
تريد ان تحفظ القران لنفسك انت وتعمل به
من ناحيه القران
فصاحه القران تفسير القران تجويد القران
علم المقامات او مثلا في تدبر القران مثلا
انا كماليزي ان على الاقل اقرا القران
افهم معاني القران باللهجه
العاميه الماليزيه حتى اشرح للمجتمع
ويكون الانسان
عندما ينوي
من يرد الله به خيرا يفقهه في الدين فاذا
اردت ان تحفظ القران لابد انك يكون لديك
نيه صافيه لله لوجه الله سبحانه وتعالى
فبدايه انا تعبت في حفظ القران
وتعلم تجويد لكن هي مراحل وتعدي لكن
الانسان دائما يحاول ان يتقن وان يتلقى
دائما علوم القران والعلوم الشرعيه اذا
قابل احد العلماء والمشايخ والقراء
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]